(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] I love this. Is that quartz?
- [Chris] Uh, it is.
- It's quartz?
- Thank you.
- I love quartz.
- Somebody told me-
- Bringing in the good juju.
- I know. Somebody told me
about quartz a long time ago
and I was like, "Look, I don't
know if it works or not,"
but I put it out by
the moon, I load it up.
I do all the things, just in case.
- I mean, I'm wearing all the-
- I know. Just in case,
jade it up. I do it all.
I don't know if it's real or not but,
- It makes me feel good.
- Why not? Why not?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It is if we say it is.
- Yeah, it is if I say it is, as well.
(both laughing)
- We were just talking about Graceland.
You live in Tennessee, right?
- I do, I do.
- Have you ever been to Graceland?
- I have! As a matter of fact, I went,
when I was on the show, we went,
'the show', "Idol",
we went to Graceland
- Because it was the week,
- Oh!
- That was the week I got voted off
- (laughs) doing Elvis.
- No.
- And it was the week I was most proud of!
I did "Suspicious Minds",
I'm like, "I know this jam."
And, yeah,
that was, um,
so I got to meet Priscilla
- And Lisa Marie
- Wow!
- And it was an incredible
experience, yeah.
- Oh, my God, I've missed that.
- A couple times. And we're
actually getting ready
to perform there. They
have a venue there now.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- Oh, wow. See, I gotta go check it out.
I've lived in Nashville for, like, ever,
- I can't believe you've never been.
- 12 years, I never, I never.
- I can, I work a lot.
- (both laugh)
- But I just, yeah, I never made it there
and I don't know how I did it.
But, I love that you live in Nashville.
It's such a great place to work and live.
- It's a good place
- Yes, yes.
- For musicians
- Yes. Very much so.
- of all different genres, I feel like.
- Yeah. I have so many friends there
and we never see each other. (laughs)
- Oh, my God! That's the
biggest joke here for me.
Everybody's like, "What do
you do in your off time?"
And I was like, "Oh, that's a cute term."
- Yeah, I'm in bed by nine o'clock, easy.
- 'Cause when you're
a parent, you're like,
"Um, I get home from
work and then I parent,
so that's what I do. I'm so cool."
But speaking of being a parent,
everybody has had a rough few years.
Especially with mental illness.
And I know you lost your
stepdaughter, Hannah,
- to suicide.
- Yeah, yeah.
- How have you been doing?
How's your wife been doing?
It was right before the tour.
I lost my mom to cancer,
- Oh my God.
- And then
- Exactly one week later,
lost my daughter to suicide.
And it's been,
- Geez!
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's been a learning,
I mean, for all of us.
I think the hardest thing that I found,
because I dealt with
both very differently,
processed both losses very differently.
But, I think the hardest thing,
and the common denominator
in both is the guilt.
The, "I wish I would have said this,"
"I wish I would have done this,"
"I wish I would have called more,"
"I wish I would've-"
- [Kelly] All the thoughts.
- All the things.
"Oh, this would be a time
that I would call my mom,"
Or this would be a time that I would be,
"Hey, Mom, I'm on 'The Kelly
Clarkson Show'." You know?
And so,
those moments of
the guilt is the hardest
because you can't do anything about it.
And there's always gonna be reminders
of what you could have done or whatever.
And I tend to beat
myself up a lot over it.
But it's been, uh,
it's been a very healing time
in our house,
and we dealt with it
in a very healthy way.
And our kids, you know,
were part of
the burial.
And watching my kids,
I'm kind of going off the topic here,
but we did a natural
burial that she wanted.
And my kids, I don't know if you know,
but basically it's
a basket,
so to speak,
and it's a place in Tennessee
that does natural burials
and we all had shovels
and we all got to cover
the basket.
And seeing my kids do that
and seeing them process,
it was a very
heavy, magical,
it's hard to explain.
But seeing them process that,
- I've never heard of
- and being a part of it,
- that kind of burial.
- It's incredible.
And it was,
- It seems kind of healing
- very healing
- Healing to be a part of that
and see them be a part of that
and have everyone there
be a part of it,
it's not just sitting on the outside.
Everyone was involved and it was very
- healing, yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Well, you're performing a song
off your album, "Dearly Beloved",
and this is your first release,
is it on your own label?
- Yes.
- How does that feel?
- Very liberating.
- Yeah, freeing, yeah.
- To not have anybody's voice but your own
and your tight circle of producers
and writers that you work with.
I wasn't chasing anything,
I wasn't trying to write a
radio song, or this or that.
It was just, "let's write,"
and that was such a gratifying experience.
- I love that for you
- I'm the most
- Proud of this record
because of it, you know?
- Oh man, I love that
for you, as an artist.
- Thank you.
- That's really cool.
That freedom is cool.
- Thank you so much, Chris.
- Thank you for having me.
- Thank you for coming.
- (audience cheering)
- Time for a break everybody.
Daughtry's latest album
is "Dearly Beloved".
You can get it right now
wherever you get your music.
And stick around because
Daughtry is performing
later in the show with a beard.